dink-dink
hello everybody welcome back to the
podcast I hope all of you are doing well
this week and moving forward for the
time being it is just me it is just
Julian you know this is the Jenna Julian
podcast used to a big party at the
beginning of us thinking it up and
high-fiving but it's just me this
weekend Jenna will not be here she is uh
not currently online and I will link a
short clip down below if you would like
more info on that but it's just me here
today so you and I we're gonna hang out
just a little bit all right
yeah so if you're if you're curious
about why it's just me here more info on
that is in the link down below its it's
a twitch highlight it's from basically a
week ago but I was trying to think about
how well first of all it's trying to
think about how to do a solo podcast
because it's interesting if the dynamic
is a bit interesting right because it's
like I'm used to having a back-and-forth
with a person right but then again I
stream a lot of the time and that's
really just me talking to myself like
I'm talking to you guys in chat but at
the same time if you're like if you're
just from the outside looking and it's
just one person talking to themself so I
figured I would kind of makes the two a
little bit so I went to discord or
discord and I got some of you guys to
send in some questions and if you wanted
to get advice for me I don't know why
anyone would want that so I have a few
different things that I guess I'm gonna
try to talk about with you guys based on
some of your feedback
and we're just gonna hang out for a
little bit this episode is brought to
you by post mates you've heard us talk
about post mates a lot of the greatest
delivery app if you would like food
delivered to you and you don't want to
go get it post mates is there they got
your back
alright and they don't just deliver Pad
Thai despite what you may think based on
listening and watching me talk about Pad
Thai they have all sorts of different
foods that you might want delivered they
also have non-contact deliveries now
offered so you don't have to have any
sort of personal human contact physical
and you can stay distant and they're
very accommodating so right now download
the post mates app and use code Jenna
Julian for a hundred dollars of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days of using the app check it out also
guys me undies changing the underwear
game with softer than soft sustainable
undies and fun prints and three times
softer than cotton you know how much we
love me and these alright so go to me
undies Emme UND IES comm slashed in a
julienne 15% of your first order
hundred-percent satisfaction guarantee
and free shipping thank you to our
sponsors what do you think peach she's
asleep by the way you noticed when it's
just me and peach here there's there's
no dog he's clawing at my feet Kermit
he's calling it something else
downstairs he's just he's nasty wherever
he was actually Kermit today steps on a
bee oh my god he is he's a disaster
child I think someone said that in like
a comments section or maybe was our
friend
someone said Kermit was a disaster child
and it is it is raining so true
just knowing him and seeing him on a
daily basis he's just like everything
that could happen just happens to him I
like it's I don't know he he just has
that about him he's so he stepped on a
bee everyone all the dogs were outside
walking around it was a hot day and he
just he goes through and we're like oh
God
happen and he runs over and he's like
limping and his paws like a little red
luckily he's not allergic to bees and we
know the protocol for what happens but
boy he's he is truly just he is truly
just something special and I know he's
not here right now you haven't maybe
seen him for a little bit but he's doing
well other than getting stung by a bee
today so I mentioned earlier that I was
going to use our discs or if you don't
know what discs or it is it's it's an
awesome community based server that we
have primarily that that I use for the
stream it's our twitch stream I'll leave
a link down below if you'd like to join
but there's a bunch of different chat
rooms and channels or people can talk
about stuff or submit pictures or
whatever it's it's very cool platform
anyway there is a podcast suggestion
group that we have and a lot of you guys
have been jumping in there with a lot of
really really helpful suggestions on you
know things that I could do solo in the
podcast because for the time being
that's that's what's gonna be it's gonna
just be me on the podcast so I want to
thank you guys everyone who's
participated in this awesome list of
really good ideas I'm gonna be going
through the discord on a regular basis
now trying to put together cool content
that I could that I can make for you
here just sitting and talking I know
it's a like I said earlier it's like
you're used to two people so to have one
is a bit different but at the same time
I do feel like the I don't know I think
one of the special parts about a podcast
is they sure to feel like you're just
you're listening in on a conversation
even if it's sort of like a stream of
consciousness I I personally listen to a
lot of solo podcasts and I it's weird
because I listen to them but I also
still don't know how to do them a lot of
stuff I listen to is actually much
higher like higher production and
there's a lot of people behind the
scenes even though it's just one person
on the podcast so I don't know I do want
to give a a special shout out to someone
in the discord by the name of cardamon
who suggested for my solo podcast I just
played Jenga by myself so that it would
be the Jenga and Julian podcast now
first of all your brain I love it
so thank you but second of all I
actually literally scoured our game
closet I was like - we have Jenga come
on please and we don't have it we don't
have Jenga I would have done it I
literally would have done Jenga by
myself and it would have been the Jenga
and Julian podcast maybe in the future
though it also would be really [ __ ]
loud when [ __ ] like fell down but I
never I never lose so it would be fine I
wouldn't if I lost it would only be to
me alright so we don't have to worry
about it I also saw a lot of you guys uh
suggesting that I have guests on
obviously in current conditions that
would probably be probably be virtual
like on on voice chat or FaceTime or
something like that which which I'm
totally down for and you also suggested
calling
thing fam and talking to you guys and I
think both of those are good ideas and
I'd be down to explore them I just might
need a little more time to prep doing
something like that
so I hope you understand that the first
podcast by myself it's not just this
crazy high productions solo show here
I'm just kind of making do with what I
got but I really wanted to you know just
kind of talk directly to you guys kind
of how I would on a twitch stream except
this is a little less instant I wanted
to read some of your questions and maybe
some of what you want advice on and see
if I could just kind of talk you through
some of it or even just like listening
to me
I don't know work it through and my
brain might help you a little bit even
if I don't even know what I'm talking
about so that's kind of what I want to
do so I'll just go down I found a few
questions and stuff so I'll just I'll
just
Pandora's Fox's question excuse you a
question what have been your pros and
cons of working a non traditional non
nine-to-five career what would you do
differently if you had the chance
super stoked for the podcast so first of
all I haven't read these I'm just gonna
kind of go through and like process and
respond live because I kind of feel like
that's how I just want to do them you
know it's kind of interesting because I
never really saw myself doing
nine-to-five as like a permanent kind of
life solution for a career I've done
nine-to-five absolutely I've spent most
of the years in college doing
nine-to-five whether it was jobs or
internships and shortly after college I
was doing radio production for a while
and that was nine to five but yeah like
even when I was like in high school in
college and just like thinking about
what I wanted to do I never envisioned
it being some sort of kind of regular
job so to speak like quote unquote
I think the pros and cons we've
definitely talked about I've definitely
talked about but you know I think one of
the pros and cons is that you're your
own boss and I say pros and cons because
it's hard to self-motivate it's hard to
stay on yourself and set a schedule and
stick to it and enforce rules and you
know meet standards and really take a a
critical look at what you're putting out
into the world whatever that may be even
if it's completely not at all like what
I do it's just it's a difficult thing to
learn how to be your own boss and with
that said there's something really
empowering about going through that
process of learning to be your own boss
you develop a lot of different I think
professional skills like work skills but
you also it kind of develops your
personality into at least for me it
feels like a more mentally focused one
and I think it's it's one of those
things that just takes a lot a lot of
time and a lot of repetition
and a lot of trial and error like it's a
little bit trial by fire I was lucky to
have probably the world's greatest
mentor in this whole kind of Internet
path that I've taken but at the same
time you you do just learn from doing it
so I would say I would definitely feel
like the pros outweigh the cons there
obviously otherwise I wouldn't be doing
what I'm doing and I guess kind of
relating the question to what we're all
going through right now with kovat is
like you know everyone's most everyone
is moving to doing work from home now
provided you can and have the ability to
and I feel like a lot of people are sort
of going through that process now
involuntarily of like how to be your own
boss and how to be productive at home
when there's many distractions or the
world is on fire and you just whatever
and your boss isn't there to tell you
what to do like I think a lot of people
are also going through a similar
situation just it's it's kind of brought
on by a much different climate but would
I do something differently if I had the
chance I don't think so I mean I think
what has led me to here has been a lot
of learning and I don't think that there
are a ton of jobs out there that people
I mean maybe there are but the way I see
it is like it's based on like my
personal experiences with friends and
people I know and people who have
nine-to-five jobs and I talk to and
family and stuff like that I don't often
hear people talk about like nine-to-five
jobs and like cookie cutter jobs being
something that you like look back on and
reflect on and learning a lot from it's
sort of often times and I hope I'm not
like being offensive here but like
oftentimes or means to an end right like
you'd take a job to pay the bills and
you have your eye on something past it
and maybe while you're there you have a
different idea and you go this way and
you're a different nine-to-five but like
for me looking back at my time being my
own boss I'm working online and being in
non-traditional work is like I really do
feel like I've worked a lot and I feel
like it's turned me into a better worker
so that in my future endeavors I've
I've developed a skill set that I never
thought I would ever develop and I don't
think it's there's a lot of ways to like
plan out that you're gonna try to do
that it just it just sort of happens and
you either go with it or you don't and I
decided to kind of go with it that was a
super long-winded responsible I'm sorry
for that
did you ever live on your own if you did
what are some things you did to keep
yourself company live on my own um yes
no no I I'm really good at this you guys
know technically I never lived by myself
alone what I did was for most of my
college years I lived with her roommates
and as many of you probably a lot of you
guys know when you live with roommates
especially in like college years or even
after college or whatever it's very
possible that you just don't really see
a lot of your roommate mm-hmm
because of their job and their schedule
being different than yours and I mean
I'm sure there's a lot of situations out
there where people are sick as [ __ ] of
their roommates I'm gonna what can you
get out of the house my guy but for me I
really I did have a lot of alone time in
those years when I was living with
roommates and you know I don't know I
mean how do you cope with being alone
it's it's it's hard you know as I think
you find I think it's important that you
have things that can take up like the
fit kind of two criteria one they can
take up time right things that you can
sync time into gaming reading something
physical exercise yeah extras like
something physical or you know hobbies
things that you are there are tangible
activities that you have to you know
it's not just watching TV right like
it's these are hobbies that you have to
kind of apply yourself so you're you're
at least mentally occupied while you do
them for me that was really important
when I lived alone
I was really into working out in my
college years I was really into I did a
little bit of cycling which was really
fun I could kind of like be independent
I didn't have a car so I would like I
would cycle around my college town I did
a little bit of jiu-jitsu and then you
know I also really started to fall in
love with like radio production which
which was turned out to be kind of a
hobby of mine which ended up being sort
of a job but I would definitely think
that like you really just got to do your
best at finding those things that take
up time and when those kind of work in
tandem with your like relaxation time
and your like Netflix time and your
chill me time like it's kind of it's a
sort I sort of feel like they work
together really well
because on one hand you have your
comfort zone where you're able to watch
your shows and eat your favorite snacks
and listen to your favorite music and
talk to your friends online and and then
you on the other hand you have something
that you're trying to work towards
getting better at and both of them take
up time and both of them only require
you most times maybe some partners and
whatever other activity you're doing or
stuff like that but I think balancing
those two things can be really helpful
with with feeling lonely and also you
know not to put pressure on yourself
that you need to be social I so much of
that pressure growing up and especially
in college because I was definitely the
most isolated in my life in college
there I just really didn't fit in with a
lot of people in my school and I spent a
lot of time alone and I I think learning
and telling yourself over and over that
that's okay like that's not a bad thing
I think that's an important reminder an
important reminder for you to not feel
like you're doing the wrong thing or you
need friends to be successful or
anything like that you know what I mean
like it's it's definitely hard but um I
don't know being alone can be cool
Thank You ABS by the way for that
question mm-hmm all right
Sachi ray says I've been struggling to
find motivation to create art after two
years of being forced to do art in
college that I didn't feel anything with
it's been almost a year of me avoiding
art and it still sometimes makes me feel
sick when I think about trying do you
have any advice on how to remove that
bitterness of a tutor picking apart work
and gaining my love of the Hobby back
motivation can be hella dumb sometimes
satchi thank you for your message and I
hear that man like that's it's always
it's always like a weird situation when
you when there's something that you like
or that you love or that you find
pleasure in in life ends up in a
scenario that makes you not like it
anymore
like that that sucks man that really
sucks because it's pretty clear that
you're a passionate artist but you had
this experience where you were forced to
do it and it sounds like Pete you know
people like tutors we're picking apart
your work and making you feel like it
wasn't good and that sort of deterred
you from the activity altogether and i
thats that's really shitty and I am
sorry that happened my I guess my advice
for like getting back into it and
feeling like it can be a positive outlet
again you know I think I think it's one
of those things where you have to I
think you have to really try to separate
the outside world from your your
favorite thing to do right there one of
your favorite things to do your hobby so
in this scenario where you were in an
art class and you felt like doing art
and getting you know picked apart for it
not being right or the good result that
they were looking for and you were left
to feel a certain way that they didn't
really address if you sort of put a line
between your art and your activity and
then the outside wheels on the other
side and on the other side is
social media friends and family thinking
about past experiences doing that same
activity really just try to focus in on
you know just isolating it it is it is
drawing it is painting it is sculpting
right turn on some of your favorite
music really just remind yourself over
and over this is this is mine this is
for me like you're doing it for yourself
no one ever needs to see it and think
about the process of doing it as therapy
right like you have your music on open
up a window get our nice breeze going
and just try to let try to let yourself
go try to let yourself kind of just fall
into it for a short amount of time it
doesn't need to be you don't need to
hold yourself accountable for like oh I
got to really hit it hard every day and
do this if you're trying to fall back in
love with with art take baby steps and
really just focus on the relationship
between you and the art not your art and
the rest of the world because I feel
like unfortunately like your scenario
that you described it's so toxic to have
other people jump in between you and
your passions and make you despise each
other like that's that is frustrating
and I totally I totally agree motivation
can be super [ __ ] tough sometimes man
I mean even if it's like even if it's
something that you know you like doing
like motivation is hard because because
you're an ever-changing person and life
always has variables and the weather
take changes and it's just life is life
is hard so I I hope that you can satchi
I hope that you can find a way to kind
of fall back in love with art speaking
of art me Andes has some really cool
artwork on there undies
I don't know if you've seen it they do
have their plain single color undies for
you okay if you're not you know into
craziness and you don't want Flair they
have your plain colors but they also
have really really cool new prints all
the time oftentimes from really talented
cool artists they do really cool collab
so
you got to check it out go to me undies
right now me Andy's calm slash
annejulien excuse me and before you
decide you want to you know just jump
into it buy your first pair just look
around they have so many different items
they have underwear they have brought
lets they have onesies we are big fans
of their onesies and the coolest part is
it really never gets old they're
constantly putting out new designs and
colors and fun things for you to wear
especially while you're at home once
these are the [ __ ] quarantine outfit
baby do it to him go to me undies comm
slash Jenna Julianne get 15% off your
first order free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee they also
have a me on these membership which
gives you new pairs sent to your door on
a regular basis alright and they give
you site wide site wide savings on a
slew of different other products so
check it out click link down below also
guys post mates if you don't feel like
going out into the world post mates is
there for you right now
and always to bring you your favorite
foods ok I admittedly have been using it
quite a bit lately it is very helpful it
is also a really good way to support
local restaurants in your neighborhood
that you would love to support both
because you like their food and you know
that times are tough right now and you
want them to have your business post
mates allows you to help you to help
them out so check it out download the
post mates app on iOS or Android browse
around
look look what's in your area just
search swipe look around check out the
menus they have really beautiful food
pics on there and then just order and
then it'll be brought right to you
whether you you know your home or your
working or whatever it is they will
bring you your food and right now if you
download the app and enter code Jenna
Julian you get $100 of free delivery
credit for your first 7 days when you
download the post mates app anything you
need postmates it thank you again to our
sponsors for supporting us and being
good peeps
huh how do you get motivation when life
has been canceled anticipation and plan
travel family and friend events are on
endless hold it seems like there's
nothing to be motivated for forget 20
thank you for your participation here
man what a question you know I feel like
that's something we can all relate to
right now and some days it is very very
hard it feels like you know it sort of
feels to me like with the pandemic going
on and everyone's life coming to a weird
slow crawl it sort of feels like the
first time in my life and people around
me life that I'm facing something that I
1,000% never ever prepared for right
like there are certain things I feel
like that you go through in life changes
and transitions and different events
good bad that you might that you might
struggle through and you you probably
have gone through hardships and things
like that but this really feels like an
event that there has been no preparation
there was been no sort of coaching on
how to go through something like this
you know like you're you when you grow
up you learn you talk to your friends
your parents give you the birds and the
bees like you learn about different
things that might happen in your life
and how to go through them even if those
things even if those the way you learn
them or the people who teach you or talk
to you aren't helpful you've at least
kind of gone through something where
it's like at least we talked about at
least I knew this was a possibility this
feels like it wasn't even anywhere in
the manual it's just happening and it's
so insanely intense
and serious and relentless first of all
I want you to know that like you're not
alone so many people right now are
feeling this way and everyone's going
through everyone's trying to like figure
it out how how to deal with it how to
move forward how to feel normal how to
be productive you know what I would say
is you know try to think back on I know
this sounds a bit like try to think back
on memories of traveling and look at
pictures and and maybe think about in
the future like not not tomorrow or not
next month but like the future where you
might want to go and you know it's it's
also another one of those things where
you really are kind of forced to like
think about times when you took things
for granted I don't ever remember
thinking to myself before this this year
man I was I don't know what I you know I
aside from like an injury or something
man I don't know how I could ever be so
grateful for the fact that I get to
train jiu-jitsu every day or I man I
flew to visit my friend this weekend and
it man I'm so lucky that I could do that
I mean obviously you have gratitude
right and if you can go places and do
things you have gratitude but being able
to do it being physically able to do
those things I'd I definitely didn't
find myself during those moments really
being thankful and now looking back I'm
like [ __ ] that was dope that I could do
that and I definitely can't right now
there's a lot of things that everyone's
being stripped from in their life and a
lot of those things that you're losing
have have really important roles in your
life they sort of define you they have
they're part of your like personality
makeup and when they're gone it's it's a
struggle it's hard I don't know forget I
really wish I had an answer for you I
just think that like you know really
focusing on hobbies at home you know
focus on your communication with your
family and friends
you know that's an important thing a lot
of people are it's like one of the
silver linings there's a lot of people I
feel like our facetiming and talking to
their family and friends a lot more
right now because everyone's at home and
there's time and stuff like that you
know and really just thinking about the
times when you could do those things and
know that they will come again you know
in one way or another they will come
again so it's tough though I uh I hear
ya Elana Rachelle says do you have any
suggestions for how I can stop defining
my self-worth by my academic
achievements oh boy first of all I think
I think I don't know what you know what
stage in your education you are but I'm
assuming either high school or college I
will I think using high school as as
sort of an analogy for like education in
general is kind of good like looking
back on my high school experience like
there were a lot of you know I played
baseball I loved playing baseball I
loved the friends I made playing
baseball and I think it shaped me as a
person I was one of the huge positive
things about high school and looking
back I'm so glad for it because I think
without baseball I would have just truly
despised high school I didn't love high
school but I think it would have really
[ __ ] sucked without baseball
anyway tangent my point is looking back
on high school I do remember being in my
high school aged head and what things
looked like to me and how I thought
about the world and how [ __ ]
important every little thing that went
on in my high school was to me it was
like everything's so important you know
social things with friend groups and
doing well in class and getting into
college and playing well on bait on my
baseball team and getting recruited to
play at college it and
finding a girlfriend like the things
that you go through in high school when
you're there I just remember it being so
goddamn intense everything is such a big
deal and then graduate and a little time
passes and you look back and you're like
why why did we care so much it doesn't
even matter like none of that mattered
like it mattered in a sense that it was
a stage of your life and you know you're
developing teenaged person and you know
it's important to get educated and go
through that experience but like in the
grand scheme of life a lot of it was
just so so small and you don't really
see that until you're out of it like you
get out of high school and you're like
wow how did I care so much none of that
really is even a big deal and you start
to think about the people that maybe
gave you [ __ ] or the people that really
made your life hell or whatever or even
like the people who had you know who
were the studs and I had like the great
high school experiences and they were
the prom king in Queens and you're like
I wasn't even that cool like where did
that what like where did that bring them
to right now it was just an isolated
thing that happened in the stretch of
years that when you're done everyone's
done everyone moves on everyone goes
into you know different different things
and um I think I think thinking of it
like that might help you I don't know
that it will though you know I know that
like the stakes are higher after high
school
like college and grad school and getting
any sort of degree that you might be
chasing like things are important so I'm
really not trying to minimize that I
want you to understand that whatever
education and academic achievements
you're referring to I'm sure are very
important and I'm it's probably a good
thing that you are leaning on the side
of defining yourself by them in the
sense that you care about them obviously
you're way more than that though you are
not your academic achievements that is
just a small part of you you are Alana
you have friends you have family
you might have a pet you might have a
laptop where you play minecraft you
might have a favorite restaurant you
might have a hidden talent you know any
mean like there's so much that makes you
up that makes you probably a wonderful
person and academics are just a piece of
that and so thinking of it like that you
know your makeup is just a whole mix of
things right and one of those things is
academia but it's only one of those
things it's not the whole thing it
doesn't comprise you as a whole try to
remember that I guess and looking at it
from that angle again really want to
reiterate that I'm not minimizing how
important education is and how stressful
and you know huge it feels while you're
in it it's it's definitely intense and I
applaud you for getting educated for
sure I hope I'm doing okay by the way I
don't know I don't know if I'm doing
well I kind of I'm kind of just like
going yeah I don't know there's no
there's no instant feedback so I'm just
like oh I don't know this is this good
or bad
that's the one thing about Twitter I
feel like if I'm if I'm if I'm off I'm
gonna get yelled at right away so it's
like I know please don't yell at me less
he says advice on coping with a friend
or loved one passing away especially if
it's sudden and unexpected or even
self-inflicted on a less heavy note okay
I'll get to that in a second so the
losing people losing loved ones is very
very difficult
I had to go through it many more times
than I really ever thought I would by
the time I'm 28 and uh there's it's hard
to give advice on something like this
because I don't even think I know how to
deal with it you know I just really AM
feel I feel blessed that I have someone
who is my person in there for me and you
have a loving family that can support
you and friends that can support you and
be there for you because going through
loss alone I imagine is just just awful
and just the worst thing ever and I
don't wish it upon anyone ever so I
think as much as it might be hard at the
beginning you know you have to take your
time to really kind of process it but
find people in your life that really
care about you find friends that are
actually there for you that really want
you to be okay that that you can lean on
and don't feel like you have to go
through it alone it's tough man it's
tough especially when it's sudden
especially when it's especially when
it's suicide it's very tough and I've
gone through that and just know that
with time life gets a little bit easier
because it really does feel like the
whole world is crumbling when something
like that happens and nothing really
matters and you're just so sad and you
don't care about things and you crying
and it's it's a lot you know in time the
memories of that person and the good
times and the happiness that they once
brought you will become this the
centerpiece of of their memory right
like when you think of them you know
you're always gonna be sad that they're
not there anymore that's something that
I don't think ever goes away but over
time I think the the good memories of
them and the happy times that you had
will will be quicker to come to your
brain when you think about
it does get you know I I went through
something like this and I think a lot of
you know that
and every year I visit you know I visit
them at the cemetery and you know the
first year we did it was really hard but
really really hard and then the second
year you know it's it just gets easier
and you start to think about the good
times and you start to laugh and and
remember funny things and you know it's
just part of life I don't know it's it's
hard I feel like I'm kind of talking in
circles here but I hope there was
something that I said that could have
provided any sort of help to you I'm
sorry for your loss and I hope that you
start to feel better
let me see what else do we have here I
think what you do look one more yeah
yeah mm-hmm I really wish I had Jenga
that would be that would be pretty
incredible it would be loud though you
wouldn't want that you would hate it I
want to I want to pick one more and I
want to I want to I kind of want to find
something like that I haven't touched on
I don't want to like repeat myself a
bunch someone roasted me in here you
were to like you guys were talking about
how I was gonna do solo on the podcast
and someone said enigma said he worked
at a radio station before he did YouTube
he'll knock it out of the park no way
he's a catcher implying that catchers
can't hit [ __ ] getting bodied in here
dude what the hell
I'll just read some more of these Azura
says Julianne reads the sponsors then
sits and stares deeply into the camera
for 30 minutes suddenly the camera
begins to zoom in on his face
he remains still the Aries energy builds
in intensity boiling behind his eyes and
he lets out a nap pep and the show ends
I should have done that that would have
been good get food delivered and pretend
I'm Guy Fieri there's a lot of good
ideas in here oh I'll also check out
maybe the comments section here on on
this podcast but I encourage you if you
you know if you want join our discord
and you can partake in in responding
with ideas or suggestions or even just
hanging out with other people and chat
we actually last night I just made a
brand new channel called tattoos where
you just go in there and talk about your
tattoos and share pictures and you're
like oh cool tattoo me too cool
so that's kind of what discord is like
someone else said I should interview the
dogs I kind of feel like listening to
that might be an issue a peach you want
to get interviewed give my baby a sleepy
sleepy girl would you like to be
interviewed
ok peach have you or have you not been
caught stealing my credit card to order
doggy treats for yourself off Amazon no
nothing all right
pleading the fifth bold strategy on the
opening question why is your brother so
nasty and why are you not the same
amount of nasty
okay that's a good answer
interesting all right well thank you for
being interviewed and thank you for
being my guest on the show yeah I don't
know um
I do hope that uh if you are a you know
a frequent listen or listener or viewer
of the Jenna Jillian podcast that you I
don't know you could be at least minorly
entertained by just me being here I
don't know like I said I'm gonna try to
develop some cool ideas and things that
I could do for upcoming episodes both
with guests and how to have people on
and also interacting more with you
because I feel like the more interactive
the better honestly I think that would
make me feel like selfishly feel a
little less crazy just like speaking to
myself for an hour but yeah I don't know
I thank you guys for hanging out and
supporting how the podcast even though
there's been a some changes and things
are changing and everything's gonna be
okay and I hope all of you are safe and
well and have friends and have me time
and treat yourself and all the good
things make sure you're doing some good
self-care it is important so important
now more than ever yeah I'm just I'm
very appreciative of the ding femme and
you guys are amazing so thank you so
much for for hang and I'll see you next
week for another julen cast and I'm
gonna maybe have something worked up my
sleeve maybe I'll just be playing Jenga
who knows we'll see only time can tell
but I hope you guys have a wonderful
week
be safe be good and I'll see you I'll
see you on the next one bye
[Music]